we were just talking about how we're
gonna become experts in casting couches
after we're done with this tour and the
last tour we're gonna know a whole lot
will open up a furniture store but it's
gonna be all casting couch
yeah this material was gonna be called
casting couch deep oh yeah I mean that's
the that rolls out the tongue that feels
you think couches are us yeah there's
that
hello like casting or no we'll call it
castaways that's good yeah you know what
yeah I was talking my family in Hawaii
no note my sister broke her wrist or
something yeah skate skating how
Canadian is that I see nice oh I'm like
a lake too like a pond nice that's the
most Kayne should ever yeah really is
was she going out there to save some
type of otter or no as she was like her
she didn't want to go out there it's
like her you know her dogsled her dogs
just pulled her onto the frozen lake and
then she had to put on the skates to get
back training Balto exactly nice okay
decathlon no decathlon is this [ __ ]
where you [ __ ] you know you like
cross-country ski and then you shoot oh
is it a weirdest sport you know you
don't know that sport no I didn't know
you I thought to cath alone was like you
run bike no that's triathlon Athlon is a
whole different beast
you just run and then shoot used Ross
country ski and then you shoot like a BB
gun at like a target while skiing you
stop and do it okay and then you cross
country ski to the neck and then there's
one other thing in there I think I
forget what it is it's crazy it's the
crazy apparently it's like one of the
hardest sports that you can do just fine
shoot yeah it's weird as [ __ ] right but
apparently it's super hard because it's
hard to be super accurate when you're
like physically exhausted got it it's a
bunch of like former snipers and Mauri
cameramen do the [ __ ] what
someone sent us a clip of a Maori
cameraman doing what's up Mari camera
like Mari like the TV show
Oh Maury hey Mort Maurice hurry Mauri
Mauri a Maury yeah singular okay yeah
one of them dudes just like chasing a
girl she found out her dude wasn't the
father and yeah he goes running down
like the hallway it's just hella funny
she goes all the way down she's about to
go to the parking lot yeah he turns into
the cops camera man that is yeah
non-stop nothing fences yeah can't stop
this guy is a machine yeah those are the
guys doing decathlon yeah I want it I
want to address something real quick
that a comment that we got like on like
probably five six episodes ago maybe
even further than that sure it was some
dude that says whenever Cody says
something stupid he says oh that's just
how we say it in Canada or that must be
how oh yeah yeah yeah stop covering up
you're like you're solidity with being
Canadian because I'm from Canada we
don't do any of that [ __ ] and to that I
say maybe you're just from the east side
of Canada side we do do a lot of those
things but yes no I I do agree with you
I do sometimes cover up by Canadian IDIA
seas I blame it on the on my homeland
and that's not something that's
disrespectful it's honestly it is and so
to that I say actually I'm sorry I'm
sorry nice to just stealing [ __ ] that's
I'm Canadian sorry we do it differently
up there everything's free
everything's covered by taxes yeah
exactly it's it's universal it's just
owning things yeah yeah this is
universal goods yeah you can just walk
into a grocery store and all to have
that oh this was yours yeah it's mine
man if I have that yeah thanks dude no
go ahead
that would exalt it that would explain
why you eat everyone else's food mm-hmm
just a product of being raised in Canada
man
no I was talking my sister she broke her
wrist and so she's got this big ugly
casts on and I was like is that it's
like it's like blue or something is that
the only color you just say I was
between this and yellow or something
else something else ridiculous and she's
like a professional ride you gotta go to
work yeah we're like a pantsuit or I
don't know whatever professionals wear
and
it's like an eyesore yeah and so I was
like what if you had like a cool cast
cover like you could use to camouflage
the cast or maybe match your outfit that
day and it would be called cast away all
that all that to cast away so I stole
your business idea uh-huh all right then
we gotta come up with a new name for the
casting couch store castaways is taken
Oh what could what could we do what
mattress stores are always really stupid
and on the nose you know so I was like
dream sleep dream beds and beds for you
uh-huh
about sex couch yeah just just right to
it mm sex sofa yeah how about um
lazybone there we go yeah lazybone there
we go hey I like that that's good damn
that was quick only took us 20 minutes
of talking about lazybone other stupid
business yeah just figure out the
punchline yeah lazybone is solid Debbie
Debbie fireman I mean that that is a I
think of necessity in today's in today's
climate I love that phrase what Clark
and I are talking about that in today's
climate such a just a non-smart phrase
that people like to use it sounds smart
though makes you sound smart oh yeah
well in today's climate yeah well in
today's climate I would say that casting
whatever the timer there we go no you
forgot said it yeah it's all good
that's all good it's all good yeah well
I mean in this climate in this climate
yeah it would I you know all the
self-produced porn these days mm-hmm
you know it there's a need for people
who understand fabrics materials how
come and just bodily fluids affect those
materials over time that's a good point
we offer every every couch comes with a
UV light yeah free UV flashlights that
you keep your keychain so you can even
take it out and shine it on things in
public yeah there's that we do annual
servicing okay okay any [ __ ] stain larger
than
um a business card we will service for
free anything bigger than that though
it's not covered yeah anything bigger
than that not going by warranty right
yeah sorry yeah so it has to fit within
a business card
cuz you know make sure you're
consistently coming don't hold it in
yeah don't shoot it all over the place
make sure it lands in a neat little pile
not only that but like don't make sure
you're not like like you know like stock
stock income in your balls
yes storing it yeah stockpiling make
sure to distribute it regularly yeah so
you don't have like one giant huge thing
to come yeah that's like the car
dealership they service a scratch that's
a size of a credit card we do a business
card patch of [ __ ] will do that for free
you got a 15 year warranty on that
[ __ ] what else uh
damn dude that actually be a funny ass I
don't know like you know there's all
those brand deals for like what's that
mattress company that everyone promotes
Oh Casper
yeah Casper oh yeah we got to do it like
we have to do like a it's like a new-age
company yes come here it's like has a
beautiful website yeah and the gold
market the [ __ ] out of it even though
like like Casper is marketed beautifully
even though they're just reselling
[ __ ] shitty yeah Chinese mattresses
probably yeah we'll do it like that yeah
like we have to have a one-word name
yeah and it's got to be like something
dot cloud or you know exactly like you
know like Love Bone Love Bone Daioh or
something like onda now it's got to be
vaguely such lazy bone that's why man
now that that that's that's like a store
with like all tile and you walk in
there's one guy right ten thousand
square foot space like what if it was
just called something like um smash yeah
it's got like smash or um
nailed with node with no II okay nailed
mmm-hmm that's pretty like that's it's
pretty like from mid-2000s though you
think due to like remove one of the
vowels it's true it's very true what
could it like what about just like pipe
yeah that's it mmm now that's too like a
plumber
okay um it was a mother oh I'm slow
today
cake cake hmm cuz it's sexual because
it's like refers to the body
mm-hmm can but it also like it's kind of
like a soft welcoming thing
what about cheeky that's great
cheeky matches yeah cheeky couches yeah
or just cheeks it cheeks is great yeah
just cheeks so yeah it look a great name
for like a brand
welcome to the think tank episode of the
podcast it cheeks is a great [ __ ]
name cheeks sofas semen resistant up to
cheeks calm yeah semen resistant up to
like a certain pH level is common cited
I don't have up to four liters up to
four liters in flicks
[Music]